boris johnson l'illusionniste du brics
it documentaire signé walid berrissoul
on va poursuivre la réflexion autour des
conséquences possibles du bric cité des
défis qui attendent aujourd'hui
boris johnson avec nous pour cet échange
yves verte uncini bienvenue vous êtes
président g mouvement européen-france
ancien directeur de l'institut jacques
delors est avec nous également mais à
distance depuis londres marc roche
bienvenue à vous vous êtes journaliste
correspondant à londres biographe
d'elizabeth ii parmi vos livres je cite
celui ci le bric si tu vas réussir c'est
toute la question ce soir alors puisque
le documentaire se termine sur la
question irlandaise et sur les velléités
d'indépendance de l'ecosse qui sont
d'ailleurs confirmé lors des dernières
élections
je voudrais que l'on évoque l'unité du
royaume uni est elle en danger cette
unité
marc roche est ce que les progrès qu
site aurait un peu sous-estimé ce défi
l'unité du royaume uni n'est pas en
danger parce que les écossais d'abord
n'ont pas donné un mandat à c't'heure
john le premier ministre pour organiser
un deuxième référendum elle n'a pas la
majorité absolue et ensuite parce que
les cas c'est un pays a suscité
c'est à dire que sans londres les causes
s'effondrent et les nationalistes et que
celle donc toujours pas mieux point un
programme et que le lui d'indépendance
que ce soit le choix de la devise que ce
soit frontières dur ou non avec
l'angleterre et savent à 102,6 à
référendum ce que je ne pense pas cela
va sans doute jouer contre les
indépendantistes
l'irlande du nord est un tout autre
sujet l'irlande du nord
les britanniques en garde un très
mauvais souvenir à cause de la guerre
civile pendant 30 ans
s'il y a réuni fication cela ne gênera
pas du tout de se débarrasser de ce
boulet financier
le problème c'est que la république
dessus ne veut pas hérité d'un million
de protestants ils verront si ni aucun
danger pour cette unité du royaume uni
la menace ne vient pas l'intérieur
si elle est en question est d'ailleurs
en question à cause ou grâce
référendum puisque rappelons nous qu'au
moment du référendum sur le bras exit
les nations se sont exprimés ces des
nations la nation écossaise a dit non au
bras exit à 61% les nations
nord-irlandaise à 56% galles et
l'angleterre avait voté pour le bras
exit mais pas ces deux nations dont on
vient de parler et donc le substrat
démocratique c'est que les peuples de
ces nations ne sont pas d'accord avec le
brésil c'est pour ça que ça repose la
question de l'indépendance
mais une fois qu'on a dit ça sont deux
scénarii de situations extrêmement
différente parce que dans le cas de
l'ecosse bon madame stores john n'a
peut-être pas eu un mandat seule mais
elle a des alliés qui sont en faveur
aussi d'un référendum d'indépendance
mais faudrait telle qu'elle ait
l'autorisation le monde pour organiser
ce référendum
de l'autre côté l'irlande du nord c'est
différent et marc roche a dit qu'elle
était le scénario possible c'est un
scénario à la halle allemagne de l'est
si vous il ya une réunification de
l'irlande et du coup les nord-irlandais
reviennent dans l'union européenne en
attendant c'est en irlande qui a une
urgence puisque vous l'avez dit les
briques zitter était totalement
imprévoyant sur les conséquences de ce
divorce et c'est vrai que la situation
de l'irlande de séparation normalement
automatique des deux irlande suite au
bras exit n'avait jamais démissionner et
aujourd'hui on se retrouve avec une
situation très difficile parce que le
brésil c'est une sorte de divorce il a
fallu régler les questions d'argent ça a
été réglé les enfants les enfants
c'était les britanniques présents chez
nous les européens présents chez eux
leurs droits a été préservé mais il
restait à bas les soeurs siamoises
irlandaise et il faut séparer des
siamois et on n'a pas envie de séparer
des siamois ce parce que c'est très
dangereux ça arriverait
les souvenirs de la guerre civile sauf
qu'à un moment donné puisque les
britanniques ont choisi c'était leur
droit de quitter l'union européenne il
faut bien établir des contrôles quelque
part et donc c'est là que aujourd'hui la
situation est tendue parce que soient
les contrôles on les met entre les deux
irlande ce qui n'a pas été prévu ni
souhaitée ni par le royaume uni ni par
les européens dans le cadre de l'accord
soit il faut les mettre en mer d'irlande
et maintenant boris johnson se fait
comme s'il ne s'était pas engagé à cela
et qu'il ne veut pas le faire et donc ça
c'est vrai que ça va entretenir mon pas
seulement les tensions entre
londres et le continent mais aussi entre
les deux héros est ce que ça fait partie
des raisons pour lesquelles les
autorités britanniques se tournent aussi
on le voit dans le documentaire vers les
pays du commonwealth comme pour recréer
du lien ressouder une nation et
notamment avec les pays anglophones
m'accroche le boris johnson est un homme
politique à double visage il sait pas
nationaliste d'un côté il cela marche
très bien dans les bastions bressy
terres du nord et des médias comme on
l'a vu lors des dernières élections
régionales où il emporter un succès
fracassant dans cette partie là mais
sinon dans le sud qui est celui des
services d population plus éduquée
il tient un langage beaucoup plus
cosmopolite et là le commonwealth est à
dire l'ancienne famille d'outre-mer
c'est à dire les ex colomiers les
anciens et de minions va jouer à ses
yeux un rôle important sur tous les pays
émergents du commonwealth en particulier
l'inde mais aussi l'australie une
nouvelle gênant le canada mais cela va
parallèlement avec une stratégie pro
américain et bien sûr le royaume uni
reste proche de l'europe son premier
partenaire commercial avec lequel il a
des intérêts stratégiques et de défense
cela veut dire que la proche mais pas
seulement comme noël c'est un triptyque
etats-unis europe et commonwealth mais
ça veut dire que finalement le royaume
uni qui est une structure comme l'union
européenne pour se tourner vers une
autre structure alors peut-être un peu
moins solide un peu plus virtuel qui le
commonwealth
oui mais ça fait partie et ce
documentaire le dit très bien le mythe
impérial convard et susciter
l'imaginaire britannique ça d'ailleurs
ça explique en partie l'histoire du
royaume uni salles explique le bras exit
de même que sa géographie son insularité
voilà ses spécificités c'est un divorce
le dizet qui est largement identitaire
et sentimentale
vous pourrez quel point ça le royaume
uni danse comme un noël sans fin dans le
documentaire ils sont un peu déçus ils
se sont sentis délaissés les autres pays
du commonwealth par le royaume uni les
britanniques ont réussi une
décolonisation plutôt contractuels alors
que la décolonisation française était
conflictuelle notamment en algérie dont
ils ont quand même gardé des liens avec
ces pays là mais il voit si on regarde
les choses oui c'est des marchés
importants oui mais ça c'est le papier
maintenant ils commencent à essayer de
négocier avec tous ces pays là des
accords alors l'accord commercial avec
l'australie on est en train de le
finaliser ça va pas être mieux que celui
que qu'on avait grâce à l'union
européenne je dirais et puis avec l'inde
et tout le reste on verra s'il y arrive
moi je dirais que peut-être les
britanniques vont réussi à refaire leur
vie dans quelques temps en redéployant
leur alliance notamment commerciales
avec des pays du commonwealth
enfin pour l'instant on voit pas venir
grand chose sans même parler du le
l'accord fantasmé avec les états unis
alors ça devait être fait avec avec
donald trump
maintenant c'est joe biden et on entend
joe biden dira qu'il faut faire très
attention avec les deux irlande
justement on y revient pourquoi
d'ailleurs pas joe biden comme 10% des
américains est d'origine irlandaise
bien sûr y'a il ya un breakbeat
internationaliste notamment des fonds
spéculatifs là qui veulent aller faire
du business où c'est plus rentable
enfin il ya quand même une autre partie
du brésil qui était un brésil plutôt
nationaliste et protectionniste est ce
que eux ils ont vraiment voter pour le
libre échange mondial j'en suis pas sûr
et il faudra évidemment que boris
johnson dont marc roche nous rappelle
qu'il a un double discours
c'est ce qui ressort du documentaire
franchement ils s'adaptent à tous masta
la victoria siempre rien comme il dit
même à un moment
bon ça c'est le discours gauchiste
latino américains arrivent à maintenir
ces différentes positions et faire tenir
ensemble sous le contrôle de son peuple
marc roche peut être une réaction sur ce
royaume uni d'une force toute relative
écoutez moi je constate deux choses la
première chose c'est que le succès de la
campagne de vaccination royaume uni a
fait que vous entend plus du tout les
rimes et n'en est que plus personne ne
discute du break site et que tous les
sondages montrent que si le le
référendum devait jouer une nouvelle
fois
les bretteurs l'emporterait encore avec
une plus grande marge
parce que ce que boris johnson à
démontrer c'est qu'il ya un avenir hors
de l'union européenne avec l'union
européenne bien sûr mais hors de l'union
européenne il ya un avenir planétaire il
ya un avenir aussi parce que le royaume
uni la montrer à nouveau dans la
pandémie il existe un formidable
potentiel scientifique université le
soft power qui est un peu et les
industries de demain et les européens
ont une tendance à regarder le royaume
uni comme un pays en déclin en fait si
on voit maintenant les perspectives
économiques post ben raide site
d'après la banque d'angleterre elles
sont très bonnes et le royaume uni se
dirige d'ailleurs vers une une très
belle croissance un chômage très faible
parce qu'il ya non seulement une
déréglementation totale du marché du
travail mais aussi un contrôle pointu de
l'immigration comme d'autres pays dits à
savoir le canada l'australie ou la
nouvelle-zélande via le permis à points
est très belle société multiculturelle
qui fonctionne beaucoup mieux que sur le
continent et c'est pour ça que moi je
suis au petit moment qu'ils étaient
jimenez lors du vote qui est votée
remain je suis plutôt content que nous
ne soyons plus dans l'union européenne
puisque je suis citoyen britannique au
chaud et ça c'est très clair c'est ce
qu'on entend dans le discours des
autorités elles vont s'atteler elles
vont tout faire pour montrer qu'elles
ont bien fait de sortir de l'europe est
ce que ça peut aussi d'ailleurs se
manifester donc ça c'est manifester via
les vaccins il ya une espèce de
concurrence à entre le royaume-uni et le
reste de l'europe
est-ce qu'il peut y avoir cette
concurrence sur le plan économique est
ce qu'on peut avoir un royaume uni
presque sans foi ni loi pour prouver à
sa population qu'il a bien fait de
sortir de l'europe mais il ya deux
choses différentes
lorem unis avaient déjà beaucoup le
contrôle sur son économie sa monnaie à
un moment boris johnson dit on va
reprendre le contrôle la monnaie m'enfin
jamais personne avait enlevé au
royaume-uni la livre et le contrôle de
sa monnaie franchement donc il pouvait
déjà faire plein de choses y compris en
matière sociale et fiscale où il n'ya
pas de normes européennes
on est en manque
en direct quand même voilà maintenant
oui mais voilà bien sûr mais maintenant
mais il était déjà notre concurrent
direct mais de l'intérieur à armes
égales et la norme légale désormais pas
surtout un pâle sociale pôle fiscal
maintenant il est sorti mais du coup il
ya un accord commercial qui a été conclu
avec nous à condition qu'ils respectent
nos normes à partir du moment où il s'en
écartera non il n'y a le droit de
s'écarter de nos normes des engagements
qu'il a pris
mais à ce moment là il y aura des
conséquences et ce qui est à ce stade
son plus grand marché wii sera fermée
graduellement progressivement soit il
s'aligne sur nos normes pour avoir accès
à notre marché soit il sert l'éloignent
3 notamment les normes sur les produits
etc
on le voit bien dans le documentaire est
d'ailleurs sacré maintenant des des
frictions il faut il faut je dirais de
remplir des papiers montrer patte
blanche etc
après juste un point sur le la crise de
lakovic 19 rien n'empêchait les états
membres de recourir à des procédures
accélérées de mise sur le marché et
d'ailleurs quand les britanniques l'ont
fait ils appliquaient toujours nos
normes pour le coup c'était l'an dernier
donc les pays n'ont pas souhaité le
faire dans l'union européenne mais même
la france aurait pu aller plus vite
simplement la france n'a pas souhaité
les autres non plus par prudence pour
bien homologué les vaccins etc
toutefois la brique annexe i de l'europe
scène donne à voir pour vous pourquoi
les britanniques ont-ils fait ça en
revanche c'est bien expliqué ans le
documentaire franchement boris johnson
au début il a très mal géré l'épidémie
est donc perdu pour perdu ils ont
accéléré ils ont réussi à avoir des
vaccins dont la stratégie kaki quand
même encore soumise à caution que les
européens ne veulent plus du tout
utiliser et ils ont fait en effet une
campagne de vaccination qui est
remarquable et dont on devrait
s'inspirer simplement s'était pas
complètement lié au brésil death
moi je crois et je les dis que peut-être
brittany les britanniques
une fois qu'ils ont ont refait leur vie
bien sûr qu'ils ont des atouts ce pas
n'importe quel pays sur la carte du
monde au royaume uni mais qu' il a été
exagéré c'est la soeur de boris johnson
qui le dit très bien dans le cul de
documentaires tous que l'union
européenne l'aurait empêché de faire moi
je ne vois pas ce que l'union européenne
empêchait réellement de faire est ce que
vous sentez quand même marc roche depuis
londres qu'il y a une
nouvelle concurrence qui est en train de
s'installer entre ce royaume uni poste
pour exciter le reste de l'europe et
peut-être d'ailleurs en particulier la
france
écoutez le royaume uni totalement ancré
à lugnorre non seulement économiquement
nouveau militairement diplomatiquement
et c'est son premier partenaire
commercial
donc c'est vrai que pour l'instant il ya
énormément de bisbilles dû à
l'application de l'accord sur le break
it qui est un accord ou lourd et
difficile à appliquer un mec en gros le
royaume uni reste un pays européen est
un pays européen où vivent énormément de
remplir les firmes financières non pas
des camps paix sur le continent
ap à amsterdam qui a un peu pris de
l'enregistrement des des compagnies en
bourse
les immigrés européennes sont restées
sur tous les professionnels et sont
venus s'ajouter des immigrés d'ailleurs
parce que finalement le pourquoi tant de
britanniques de l'immigration ont voté
pour le breakbeat parce qu'ils
considéraient que la libre circulation
des travailleurs européens étaient des
chances raciste maintenant tout le monde
est mis sur le pied d'égalité
mais les sûr que l'avenir de durban yom
unis reste avec l'europe et
particulièrement avec la france vu les
intérêts stratégiques communs et le
siège au conseil de sécurité permanents
au conseil de sécurité
pour conclure et le portail perthus et
bassa sur la libre circulation des
personnes je suis d'accord pour dire que
en effet sa ses terres à des enjeux
importants du valises et parce que comme
les britanniques sont attractifs ya eu
beaucoup notamment de polonais qui sont
allés s'installer il ya eu des frictions
dans ces tel ou tel endroit du mexique
l'ironie de l'histoire comme boris
johnson a été soignée qui l'a soigné un
portugais et une néo zélandaise
d'ailleurs
aux abords des jeux vient de
démissionner du nhs parce qu'elle dit
qu'ils sont pas considérés et c'est donc
maintenant les britanniques peuvent
faire leur choix en matière migratoire
en effet ils sont sortis de l'union
européenne et plus largement écoutée bas
good luck comme le dit michel barnier à
un moment moi j'espère c'est un grand
pays qui va qui va réussir une dernière
petite question rapide est tous les deux
est ce que boris johnson incarne cet
avenir de ce royaume uni post brick city
la l'envergure île verte ont signé
ensuite marc roche c'est un bonimenteur
boris johnson il raconte une belle
histoire et donc en termes de récits il
est très bon et ben maintenant qu'ils
mettent en actes jeudi reste que ces
belles paroles ont promis marc roche
exactement je suis d'accord c'est le
seul point sur lequel nous étions
d'accord dans ce débat c'est un
bonimenteur qui n'a pas de programme si
ce n'est réussir le break it sans savoir
comment il va le cercle le problème pour
les européens c'est que les britanniques
lame bien c'est qu'il n'y a pas
d'opposition
c'est un hallyday peut-être sans vision
mais qui a bien géré la pandémie et
l'économie et qui finalement est bien
les britanniques aiment bien et tous les
stands allez y en a eu qui aurait amené
d'autres leaders a démissionné et bien
bord nous en sommes
c'était flon les scandales ne prennent
pas et ce sera la fin de ce débat merci
infiniment à tous les deux dit avoir
participé c'est donc la fin de cette
émission se retrouve très vite sur
public sénat bientôt
[Musique]